small Altar for Edgar Prado ricardina
arango spends her days alone mourning
the death of her eldest son
[Music]
he was my son he never let me be alone
he always said I want to go and see my
mother those soldiers have more
compassion for an animal
on December 15 the Army showed up
protesters outside ricardina's home
Edgar went out to help a wounded man at
the doorstep and was fatally hit in the
chest his neighbor and friend marikispe
was looking out the window when she says
helicopters flew over them she and her
husband ran to a back room for cover
terrified
I thought it was going to be like those
years ago when there were people dead
here and there I thought we have to
escape we just prayed to God
for Maddie and many in ayakucho the
violent demonstrations brought back
memories of a deadly past
ayakuto was at the heart of Peru's
internal armed conflict in the 1980s and
90s security forces and Shining path
Rebels waged a war that left nearly 70
000 people dead most of them civilians
today lawyers are collecting evidence to
build a case against the soldiers who
opened fire in December as well as those
responsible in the chain of command
on Thursday a lawyer filed a
constitutional complaint in parliament
against President Dina voluarte and some
ministers for the deaths and injuries of
protesters by police and the Armed
Forces many people who lived through the
hours the shootings went on around this
area told us they don't want to speak
about what they witnessed because they
say they're afraid of retaliation
prosecutors set a new unit of Human
Rights prosecutors will investigate the
deaths the government says the
investigations will be respected but
regardina doubts her son's Killers will
be prosecuted
I will never fall they will be free they
will be happy they have done so much
damage they have made so many people cry
will they pay someday
thousands of people disappeared during
the armed conflict of the 80s and 90s
and thousands of cases remain unresolved
regardina fears her son's death will
suffer the same fate Mariana Sanchez